Hey 18-year-old Michelle, this is Michelle from the future...
...and I have some things I would like you to know.
You are stronger than you think you are,...
...you're wiser than you give yourself credit for...
...and your first instinct is usually always correct.
You're gonna start a relationship in your late teens and early twenties...
...and you're gonna have a beautiful daughter to show for it.
The person you are at the beginning of the relationship...
...isn't going to be the same person you are when you enter your thirties.
And that's okay because people grow and people change...
...and you're gonna learn a lot about yourself.
And the thing that is going to get you through that...
...is you're gonna have a feeling deep down in the pit of your stomach...
...that everything happens for a reason and everything's gonna be okay.